so i should uh first of all thank the
organizers for giving me this talk
opportunity to give this talk
and i should apologize to frank for
giving this talk on the computer
okay
so uh i'm going to talk about
uh
complexity aspects of constructable
sheaths and i want to structure my talk
uh so if i'm going to give a talk with a
title like that i should probably give
some motivation
and i'll give some motivation some of it
i hope would be clear as i go along in
the talk so there will be some
motivation
and then i will spend quite a bit of
time on the background which i also
would like to say the qualitative part
of the talk which is going to be nothing
new but we'll
i'll try to recall some definitions
probably look at some structures in a
different way than what you might be
used to thinking about
them and then i'll mention some new
results
or
in one part which is the quantitative or
effective part and finally i would
establish
some connections with complexity theory
but i should make for this part four i
should make one well a couple of
statements
so when i talk about complexity
theory i
uh more i would um always restrict
uh
the
questions about our complexity classes
to the bloom ship's mail
model
that's what i consider as
my
and in particular in this talk it will
be bloom smail model over the real
numbers
that's the only kind of complexity
classes
talk about and i should also remark that
as frank said this theme of this
semester is about
applying geometric techniques to
questions answering questions to
complexity theory and
there was a workshop a couple of weeks
ago when a lot of
interesting mathematics was presented
they're applying these mathematics to
complexity questions my goal here is
somewhat more modest
in fact i would like to look
at
questions that i'm interested in through
some lengths of
developed by complexity people
and if there is some bash backwash back
into complexity theory that would be
even fantastic but
for the moment i'm
more interested in this other direction
okay
so
i'll just go through the motivations
quickly
so first of all we'll see that
constructable sheets provide a more
geometric language and kind of more
expressive than the usual first order
logic
which we'll
explain
it provides in a certain sense a
topological generalization of tarsky
seidenberg quantify elimination theorem
which has been
something that people have studied from
complexity aspects for a long time so it
is interesting to study these
quantitative questions in this more
general setting
something that i will not
talk about
much but i wish i should mention is that
the theory of constructable shifts in
the sense that i'm going to define as
applications in many other areas
including in
pure mathematics in d module theory or
in algebraic theory of pdes and also
nowadays
in computational geometry and topology
and finally i'm going to make some
interesting to me extensions
of the traditional bloom shoops male
complexity classes
leading to questions or
analogs of questions like the classical
p versus np-type questions
which might in fact be easier to resolve
a priory than the classical bss ones
and in any case quantitative study of
shift cohomology in a more general
setting of shifts than the ones that we
are going to discuss here might be
interesting and it is interesting on its
own right
so that's uh my
spiel
for using the start button
so now let's talk uh
let's start the background
semi-algebraic sets i really don't
probably need to recall the definitions
but
here they are so semi-algebraic sets
over real numbers are subsets of rn
which you can define by boolean formulas
whose atoms are some finite number of
polynomial equalities and inequalities
of the form p equals zero or v positive
okay those are the semi-algebraic sets
and a semi-algebraic map
well what is a map between
semi-algebraic sets whose graph
is the same algebraic set
now it follows uh just from
staring at this definition
that
semi-algebraic sets are kind of robust
category because they are closed under
various operations
like any kind of finite set theoretic
operations
unions intersections
as well as taking complements
taking cartesian products or more
generally fiber products over polynomial
maps they're close
and it's also might be takes a second
more
but it also follows from the definition
plus the fact that if you compose
polynomials then you get polynomials
that semi-algebraic sets are closed and
are taking inverse inverse images of
polynomial maps so you don't have to do
any work
to observe these
but here's a
well-known but
non-trivial fact that
tarsky in the 40s
that in fact not just the pullback
uh
uh under polynomial maps but in fact the
direct images of semi algebraic sets
under semi algebraic maps are also
semi-algebraic
now equivalently of taski was a logician
so his statement
uh
language of logic which i'm not going to
insist on too much so i'm not going to
explain what this means by defining the
first order theory of reals but i will
explain to a picture which will come
later
yes
depends on the field being the real
numbers or no this is for yeah so for
most of the talk you can assume that the
underlying field is an arbitrary real
close field but let's assume that this
real close field is the field of real
numbers without real numbers so what
what's sorry so this theorem
the general statement of the theorem is
for a real closed field this is true yes
that is true
algebraically yeah
that's left chess principle but for
i know the gm would have jumped at this
logic statement so let's uh
let's ignore this logic statement okay
but you you should have no problem with
the first statement which is equivalent
okay
all right but i am going to
make the uh
i
this next slide might look a little
pedantic but
i want to say it restate taskies
heidenberg in this kind of slightly more
pedantic way
because
of later on we are going to have some
suggestive analogies
so let's forget about semi algebraic
sets let's just consider maps between
sets let's have your map between two
sets x and y
then
just tautologically there are some
induced maps
between the power set of x to the power
set of y which are defined by taking uh
so f inverse f star is just the pullback
and it exists and f all are these
these maps
so they go from
so they go from in in those directions
i don't understand the third one the
third one is you should think
i'm looking given a set
a
i am
taking its complement
mapping and taking its complement
so if you think about universal
quantifiers eliminating a universal
quantifier
is
so what's the easiest example where
that's not the image
easiest example but
so
okay so
so if you want to say what f
uh
exists a is what is the relation with
why i put an existential quantifier well
this is the set of y
such that there exists an x in x which
maps to y
it's just in x a
x is
there's nothing anything fancy
what all x and a intersect definite
first
a
intersect
y
yep but if uh
yeah okay
anyways
that's what he said
for all
these are in opposite directions so you
might be tempted to say that they are
inverses but they are not quite
but
these maps do not are not inverses of
each other but they are somewhat
inverses in the sense that they satisfy
adjoint test relation so when i talk
about adjoint so i'm now thinking of
these maps as functors
don't be afraid of this word of between
i'm now thinking of these power sets as
categories whose objects are the subsets
of x and it's a trivial category in the
sense that i put an arrow between two
subsets if only if
the one is included in the other so
that's a kind of trivial posit category
and in if you and these are functions
between those corresponding categories
and
they are a joint and that's just a fancy
chic way of saying
that
well this
this is included in b if and only if a
is included in f star b yes yes
what is that funny symbol in the middle
i mean yeah so this means that this
function is left and joined to that
functor
yeah that's the joint and to say left a
joint means if you have two categories c
and d
you have
so this is left and join to that means
that for every object a in c
and b
in d
there is a kind of natural bijection
between
so this bijection has to be taken this
home is in d
so there's a natural bijection between
and this home is in c
but again this is all very trivial here
in this uh
in this
uh what am i doing here that's that's
fine
thanks so why don't you write before and
there exists as subscript
uh okay if you want
but i didn't i cannot fix it right now
all right
so now um
so arrow theoretically then tusky
silentbox says that if you have now semi
algebraic set and this is an important
notation i'll denote by s of x
this set of semi-algebraic subsets of x
and if you have a polynomial map
then those arrows that i defined in the
previous slide restricts not from to the
class of semi algebraic subsets
right so it goes from f uh
in these directions and they carry semi
algebraic subsystem semi algebraic
subsets and they satisfy the adjointness
relation
that starts exciting but but
yet harder fact is true
which
which is more than task is heidenberg
and in order to state it i need another
definition namely that of the notion of
triviality or semi algebraic maps
so we say
that uh semi algebraic or you can think
polynomial map which in semi algebraic
set is semi-algebraically trivial
if there exists a y
point in the base
and a semi-algebraic homeomorphism
between x and this product of the so x
sub y is a fiber
is the fiber of y
uh so if there is a homeomorphism like
this but this homeomorphism should
preserve the fiber so it should be a
fiber preserving homeomorphism
so another way of saying that
is that
this diagram here should commute where
phis homomorphism f is the map and p is
the projection on y
okay so the diagram commutes
so of course
not all semi-algebraic maps you can hope
to be semi-algebraically trivial by the
way if it is semi-algebraically trivial
then all the fibers is follows from this
definition because this map is fiber
this homeomorphism is however preserving
it follows that all the fibers are
semi-algebraically homomorphic
so of course you cannot expect that all
semi-algebraic maps are
semi-algebraically trivial in this sense
but something almost
this thing is true
so this is a theorem of heart
which says that if our arbitrary semi
algebraic map
may not be semi algebraically trivial
but there exists a finite semi algebraic
partition of the base
uh into locally close semi-algebraic
subsets
a sim
projection map which is polynomial map
from the green card onto r2 so i'm
thinking of this as a projecting from
the green carbon to r2
and then there is a
so this is not semi algebraically
trivial but there is a partition of the
of the base of r2 into three pieces
which are locally closed in the
algebraic set namely
the
complement of the curve
this open piece where the fibers are
empty in fact then the curve minus that
point
which is again a locally closed and
fibers are one point
and that point so that's the partition
and that
now i am giving this in a sequence
uh one can think of the heart triviality
theorem as a generalization of task is
either bug
why because starsky seidenbach says that
the projection the image is
semi-algebraic
so in particular this image this f of x
by heart must be a
union in fact a disjoint union of some
sub collection of the y eyes because the
fiber being empty or not
the hard partition is a finer partition
beyond the existence of whitney
stratifications and then why doesn't it
weakness satisfication is even stronger
so then i have to say harder harder
right we are not saying anything about
how these stratas fit together right so
it just
works
so if you assume so to prove witness
certification will be more than proving
hot because there is no uh condition on
the tangent spaces of so there's no
c infinity structure
but it's true it is true
about whitney conditions and things like
that but there's no whitney conditions
here
but in fact that's from the complexity
point of view
i should say that computing so very soon
we are not going we are going to be
interested in not just the theorem but
how hard it is to and how many pieces
you need
and in this case
this
stratification is simpler than the
witness stratification because then you
the complexity of witness stratification
is much
much worse because you have more
conditions
but there is some drawback here
of our theorem
that we are maintaining the
homeomorphism type of fibers but
homeomorphism type is a kind of
difficult to quantify it's undecidable
really to check whether two fibers
homomorphic
and also that the best complexity upper
bound known for this induced partition
is doubly exponential
so we come to kind of
uh
the
formalism of constructable shifts here
and the construct formalism of
constructable shifts seems to be just
the right kind of compromise
might agree or not but i hope to
convince you of this between
maintaining homeomorphism types of
fibers and just touch the side number
so here we have to take a brief detour
and i was when i was preparing the talk
it's kind of a
dilemma here
because of course for people who are
familiar with definition of sheaves
will be nothing
new but people are not familiar it will
go too quickly but i hope
which is
but i hope at least to convey to the
people are not familiar
the main geometric ideas
which should be which
which you should be able to grasp
okay so let's take uh
this little detour in any case it
doesn't hurt to
see the definition of sheets
one more time in your life for those
people
so let a be a fixed uh commutative ring
and for simplicity you are going to soon
to take a to be a field of
characteristic zero might as well take
it with rational numbers
i'll stick with a for a little bit and
then
so i appreciate on our topological space
of a modules a modules by the way so
we're not talking about complicated
shifts like ox modules or things like
that just
constantly so it associates to every
open in u
uh a module any case
field a vector space f of u
and such that
and a
restriction homomorphism for every pair
opens v and u
containing u and this restriction
homomorphism uh
so for you every time b is contained in
u there is homomorphism of the
corresponding vector spaces and it
should satisfy the obvious conditions
that you expect it to satisfy namely rf
you you should be the identity
they should compose
properly so if w contain v
you then
and sometimes so i'll for probably just
the next slide i will uh
so by the way the
these elements of s
of f of u are also called sections
and that refers to the right
picture in the first slide
if you think of
uh the constant shapes where
all these modules are just one
dimensional vector spaces then
that corresponds to sections and for
each section
in f of u will sometimes denote the
restriction by
to a
subset v by s restricted to v this
and so that's a definition of a
pre-shift
and given a pre-shift there is a more or
less canonical way to make it into a
sheath
uh so sometimes we will get free ships
that will shift fire into ships but
pre-ship is a shift if it satisfies
these two additional properties
that is for every open u and an open
covering ui of you
if
if you have two sections
that restrict to the same sections on
each ui then these two sections of u
better be equal
okay i said it with one sec one of them
equals zero but that's equivalent
and this global property namely that
for again for such an open covering if
you have sections
over each of the uis which glue together
properly namely the restrict
as
to the same sections or all pairwise
intersection then there indeed exists a
global section
uh which restricts to those ssis
fishy will be achieved satisfy this
and then the stock
which
i think of the left picture in the first
slide
so a stock
of uh of a given pre-shift
at a point x and x
is the defined to be the inductive limit
over all opens containing x
in our case
we'll have shifts which are
well let's
differ this for a moment
but unfortunately
we need something more so if it was just
chiefs it would be
simpler
but we need to go to the derived
category
so
here
the derived category
of sheeps and x
so now the objects are not just so the
category might be i should say a few
words about the category job ordinary
shifts the category of shifts on a fixed
topological space is an abelian category
so everything that you can do with
vector spaces or a modules you can do
with sheets so you have exact sequences
you have morphisms you can take direct
sums tensor products of sheets and you
get
sheets
but now we are going to go to somewhat
more nasty category namely
the derived category of sheeps and x and
this is the most difficult slide if i go
through this slide then i'm home
so um so here we can think of the
objects of these are not just sheets but
complex well we first start with
a category whose objects are complexes
of sheaths
and morphisms are homotypic classes of
morphisms of the complexes of sheaves
now this category now becomes nasty and
well then you have to localize with
respect to a class of arrows
which i don't want to say such that
complexes which are homotopic to zero
become isomorphic
and you get
the derived category and sometimes the
bounded derived category of complexes
which are bounded on both sides
now this is no longer a billion category
which is not going to bother us too much
in this talk
but it's what's called a triangulated
category satisfies axioms that take
several pages to state
but you have to replace exact sequences
by distinguished triangles and so on and
so on but there's no point in going
through this
but for our purposes it would be okay to
think of an object in derived category
as a complex of sheets even we have to
keep in mind that they're just
representing something in the derived
category
now if x is a point
then and so these are points an object
in this derived category is represented
by direct category of just complex of a
modules there's the shift is just
and in this case
this one is isomorphic in the derived
category to the complex you obtained by
just taking the chromology of this
complex
this is not true but
it depends but i'm taking a to be a
field then it's okay
that's right the function
is a field
and uh or in other words
this
thing here is uh
so that's a little bit uh
so you have to read it as uh direct sum
of complexes each one of them is zero in
only
one uh degree namely h n is zero
is non-zero only in degree n and you
take the direct so that that's uh
this is not true in general if x is not
a point you cannot think of
taking the homology and representing
effects if i have time i'll show an
example but probably i won't have time
okay so we are now going to have
operations on sheaths and in your mind
you should think of going back to this
the operations about
for semi algebraic sets namely pulling
back and pushing forward
so if you have a now
even here they are just sheets on x and
y
even if you start with shifts x and y
and if uh
it's a continuous map
then the inverse image
is going to be a sheep on x
and you don't need to go to the derived
category here because
this is a nice better functor it's exact
i don't want to explain why but
but
as usual think back again for
semi-algebraic sets pulling back
semi-algebraic set you get
semi-algebraic set for free pushing
forward is the more difficult thing
and here we have the you have to take in
order to get uh
full
information the derived direct image so
even if you start with a sheaf if you
push it forward one considers here the
uh an object in the derived category of
y so
here the object looks like a complex of
sheeps
and since the complex of sheep will do
not
by ri
the higher derived images the sheet that
you obtain by taking the homology the
ethnology of this complex and that's a
sheath so this rf star is object in the
direct category that's an ordinary shape
how do you push forward a
wow sheet
this
well r0 is just the what you would
expect right so you are given a shift
here you have an op
ship here so what would be the
associated of for each open u
in y well you take the
f inverse of u which is open in x and
you
s
so that's but that gives you just r0 but
this is not an exact functor so you get
higher derived images
it's left exact but
so but might be we should just take a
special case when
so the maps that we are going to
consider all
projections but
but it will not be exact
so in the special case uh if you take
the constant sheep on x namely that ship
that associated there we open uh
the
field a
then in this case like i will describe
what they are these higher directory
images you can think of it as
associating to each open in you complex
a modules where you
take some kind of platy resolution of a
restrictor to f inverse u and apply the
global section function
so that's a humongous
going to be a big
sheath of complexes
and but
if you take a point in y and you look at
the stock of the derived image at y
then this is after all since it's a
point it's a
object in the derived category just of a
modules
and in the category of a modules we know
that any object in the derived category
is isomorphic to taking its chromology
so in fact this stock here
is going to in the case when the shift
is a constant shift upstairs is just
going to be the direct sum of the
chromology of
the phi bar over y with coefficients in
a
so the stocks are
in the case when this is a constant
shift has this purely so this is the
ordinary chromology of the fiber if you
think of this being a map between semi
algebraic set
these stocks and f is let's say a
polynomial map the stock of the derived
image
at a point y
is really isomorphic in the derived
category
of
vector spaces or a modules to the direct
sum of the homology of the fibers
so now might be i go back to something
that's uh
high school example so whenever one
talks about uh um
well task is heidenberg this example
comes up so i stick with the tradition
so if you have a formula like that over
the reals there exist x as x square plus
2 b x plus c 0 then it is equivalent and
that's quantifier elimination for
j m
that you can eliminate so that's a
quantified statement in the first order
theory of reals
and you can eliminate this quantifier to
get an equivalent uh
formula
first order theory discriminant
non-negative
what does it mean to geometric
formulation of this
well you define upstairs
uh variety in the xbc space defined by x
square plus 2
if you look at the projection from xbc
to bc
and what you get
is uh
this picture so the pi of v i don't know
whether it's visible
pi of v is where the discriminant is not
zero so you are get so the projection is
a semi-algebraic set this closed
semi-algebraic subset of r2 and its
complement is this open part of r2 so
the fact that the projection of this
semi-algebraic set is semi-algebraic the
blue
now this theoretic version
well you consider the constant shift
upstairs
well the constant shift upstairs well
you take the constant shift on r3 but we
really want the constant shift on
v so you can think of restricting this
constant shift to v or more accurately
you just push forward the constant shift
of what
so this is
what which one was v the open with the
b is upstairs so b is defined by this
equation
x squared plus two b x plus c and then
you project v then you get the blue part
under five
b is a real variety in r3
so if you so this chief here
is um
is
whose stocks is constant on v stocks are
equal to
q uh for points in v and 0 outside
and now you look at the derived direct
image
under this map pi right and so what
about the stocks
well ah
well now it's even worse but okay so if
you want to look at the stocks then the
stocks will depend on where you are in
r2 so if you have if you are here in u
which is outside the image then the
the stock of the derived image is zero
if you are here
it is q plus q of course i'm writing
this
these
are represented by so they have degrees
right so only in degree zero there is
something non-zero and because the
fibers have no chromology
and but if you are on this on the
on the boundary here
on this locally closed well in this case
closed
uh you get since there's a double point
over the discriminant then the stock
is isomorphic to key so in this sense
just like in heart
the
fact that
the id match is if you look at the
stocks it giving you a final partition
of
of the base
okay so i might
let's hit this example
so
this example was to show the
yes
you don't keep the multiplicity we don't
keep the multiplicity it's not good no
in this constant so as i said the
is just the ordinary homology of
with coefficients in airs
so but the fiber should be no reduce the
so you should write
so if you take some more complicated
shapes okay but here we are just taking
construct
ships with constant coefficients
upstairs
yeah so it's much simpler sheets than
usual ones that algebraic geometry
should start
i'm sorry
so what did we gain looking at the high
school example by looking achieve so
what do we gain well the task is
heidenberg just tells you it's a
partition into two parts
and here is the partition into three
parts
you call i call that a little gain
okay but um but are they this uh do we
obtain the boundary as well or is this
three new parts that that are that's the
boundary but in a more complicated
example you get more complicated
partition there okay
high school example you can't expect
so
yeah so this example that i probably am
going to skip because i did not get
an anticipated question so
namely that
example was to show that the higher
direct images themselves do not
determine the object in the derived
category so if you take like the hop
vibration which is like this and the
trivial vibration which is
sphere and you look at the higher
standards going to skip this very
quickly so
they get they give you the same direct
image downstairs
even the same stocks
but
they are not isomorphic in the derived
category because if you take the
hyperchromology of one you should get
the chromology of s3 and here you should
get chromology of
fiber and
by the way for complex algebraic
geometers this kind of
is sort of used as a counter example to
this famous theorem of delene called the
decomposition theorem which apparently
is not holding here but it's okay
because in fact this is not a complex
algebraic path between non-singular
hypersurface i mean varieties it's
just an aside
okay so we have been talking about seed
but what about constructable sheaths and
this is
the following definitions of kashiwara
and shapira
so an object in the derived category
boundary derived category of x is said
to be
constructable now x is now restricted to
a locally closed semi-algebraic set
if you satisfy the following two
conditions and you have to keep the
picture of the high school example in
mind here
that there exists a finite partition of
x and to locally close semi-algebraic
sets not necessarily whitney or anything
just a finite position
locally close same algebraic set such
that the
homology of the sheets are constant are
locally constant on elements of this
partition so that's in the case of the
high school example
this is uh satisfied by this partition
and
you take this sheet so this is a
constructable sheet from r2
and on these three parts
the homology of
all the homologies are locally constant
and uh we have some kind of fight
finiteness of the stocks so the homology
groups should be finally generated
and they should vanish outside some big
upside some
i will denote this category of
constructable shifts
by this and forget about this notation
in a second i'll just call constructable
shapes on x the set of objects of this
category as cs of x
that should be an analogy of s of x
which we are defined as the set of semi
algebraic subsets of x c s of x
objects which are constructable shifts
of x
what extra flexibility is
is this buying you that's so precious to
you well
it gives you a better decomposition of
the base for the moment
did you just take the
uh as this hiding bot tells you whether
you just have two pieces in two pieces
where the fibers are empty are non-empty
it gives it retains more information
about the fibers at least in this
geometric example
and it doesn't try to deal with home it
doesn't try to deal with homeomorphism
types
so far you could have passed all the way
down to constructable functions and
still value this
no constructable functions might so
you can obtain constructable functions
by taking the euler pump area of the
stocks
but then uh you know all upon carry but
these are kind of generalized all upon
carrier could be zero for non-empty
fibers
in this example yes but imagine that you
can have a circle
yes yes are you going to explain why you
take one and not the other
well uh
so all so the constructable the fibers
here retain more information than just
the olive pancake characteristic
because for instance the olive oil
characteristic of the fiber is a circle
would vanish
why do you want to keep that information
uh that's a
more philosophical question to
to keep more information about fibers
which i think is kind of
um
if you are thinking of
projection
onto a set uh
image of a map you should really
understand
how the fibers vary
not just empty or non-empty
the oil upon carry would be a bit little
better than being empty or non-empty
this is more it's much more better
and if you take homeomorphism types it
will be even better
so in the simpler case if you just have
a finite to one map yes
then is it just the number of is just a
number in that case it will just well
not quite
because you might have a finite one map
that looks like this
it's not quite
because if you take the partition
the even though the fiber is always two
points
but
it isn't the
homology is not going to be locally
constant
but more or less
okay so
good constructible shapes
so now uh
so that's
one of the theorems of the kashivara
constructability theorem so you should
think of this again as a kind of analog
of tasky zeitenberg
which says that if you have a continuous
semi-algebraic map and you have
constructable shifts f in csx and genes
constructable shift on y then they pull
back well
the pullback of g is a constructable
shift on x
the
divided image of f is a constructable
shift from y so the class of
constructable sheaves
have this kind of stability property
that is closed not just under these
functors it's also closed under taking
all kinds of sheet theoretic
exams tensor products internal homes and
things like that
of course the theorem of kashiwaran
shapira is uh was much more and i'm not
going to talk about these other
operations but in fact the
classic constructable sheeps closed
under a wide range of ship theoretical
operation namely those
classical six operations
one of these is a cousin of after all
and the other and another is a cousin of
f exists
this one i uh these two well this is
with compact support so let's forget
about the trick so that's like f exists
if all does not have a
so you can try to
create one using some kind of duality
functor but i don't want to go there but
if you did it would be f
yes
that's right
so there is a
there is an adjunction on this category
which goes
f
up
upper shriek uh
left or joint to
star might be and then which is let's
join to
well anyway sorry i'm not going to write
it
okay so so that we should think of this
as some kind of very sophisticated
tuskey seismod so that's the end of the
qualitative background i've not said
anything
so now let's talk about quantitative
so let's go back to quantify elimination
so this quantify elimination has a
really long history it started with a
non-elementary recursive
algorithm of well because he bound on
tarsky's original algorithm for
doing quantified elimination and then
there was a kind of hiatus many people
were not looking at it
but then in the 70s
when this kind of problem became popular
because of applications in robotics and
stuff like that callings but also it's
usually attributed to columns but also
utric
gave a doubly exponential algorithm for
performing quantified elimination using
a technique called cylindrical algebraic
decomposition which is a kind of very
important technique
for triangulating semi-algebraic sets
now
there was then there was again a high
test and there was a new ingredient
called the critical point method
which was developed by
grigoriev and borabjob
and
this gives a single exponential
algorithm but i
let me state this in this statement in a
kind of
because i've talked up time in um
uh succinct way
by introducing a notation so for each n
i will denote by pi n
which forgets half the variables in rn
by projecting so that let's fix this
notation pi n
so
it was proved by renegar
in 92
that the complexity
both quantitative and algorithmic
algorithmic of the functors
so remember this is and maybe that's the
reason why i put the exist and all in
this superscript
and
which takes similarity to brexit uh
subsets of rn two semialgebraics r n
over 2 is bounded singly exponentially
maybe i should explain what this means
it means that if you are given a semi
algebraic subset of rn in defined by in
terms of let's say s polynomials of
degree bounded at most by d
then the image of this here
either of these functions is going to be
you will be able to define the image
in terms of number of polynomials and
degrees which are bounded singly
exponentially in n
and you can obtain this
description here uh going from here to
here
you know by an algorithm which also has
singly exponential complexity
uh of course this is the their results
are more precise and then we made some
more precise estimate later
but for the purposes of this talk is
just the singly exponentially the fact
the function is single exponential is
what's important
okay so that's quantify elimination but
we are going to talk about
shifts so what can we say about the
direct image functor well this is the
new statement
that if you look at the direct
image the complexity is both
quantitative the algorithmic is bounded
exponentially and here i really should
explain what
this statement means
so more precisely
if you start with a constructable shift
on rn
because we have this restriction of
having compact support
you can get rid of this restriction by
considering shapes on some compact space
like on the sphere but for the moment
let's take some of these
and suppose you have that there exists a
semi-algebraic partition of rn which is
subordinate to f subordinate in the
sense of the definition of constructable
sheath
defined by sine conditions and at most s
polynomials of degree at most d and so
on
so then there exists a semi algebraic
partition
of
r n over two which is subordinate to the
direct image sheet having complexity
which is singly exponentially bounded
might be slightly more precise but
that's the main thing that you want to
call it
moreover there exists an algorithm to
obtain this partition
from the
given partition of the same complexity
so we're going from partitions to
partitions which are partitioned
subordinate to petitions about unity
and moreover you can say something about
these talks that this if you knew
something about the stocks upstairs the
homology of the stocks then the homology
of the stocks in the direct image the
game grows at most singly exponentially
maybe a question how is
this achieved the input sheet how is it
given
on each piece
no we are not the algorithmic statement
is not about the input sheet but you are
you are taking the partition you are
given only the partition which you are
totally subordinate to the
because you say also algorithmic
so it's also when you say well yeah so
what i mean here is these three
statements
so if you are
given a semi algebraic partition
which is subordinate to some sheath you
can produce a partition
which is subordinate today
what do you need to know about the f
itself other than the you need to for
these two statements you don't need to
know uh anything other than the
partition which is subordinate
you are given a partition
can be anything yes so i'm not saying
yes
and i'm not saying that i'm able to
compute these stocks
okay this is just a bound
i'm sorry i'm still trying to see what
would you gain from this newer
formulation so
as an application of the serum would you
say would you get an easier proof of
your real algebraic toilet theorem or
something
uh i'll come back to the torah in a
moment but not an easier proof yes
so
um does subordinate to mean that f is
constant on each part or locally
calculated
even if it's locally constant so if a
constant is even better but even if it's
locally constant
so in fact we have to reduce to from the
constant to the locally constant to
constant so i i'm not going to be able
to give a proof of this theorem but i
will indicate the some of the
ingredients that go into this and one of
the ingredients is uh relates to your
question
so
so meaning one of it follows kind of in
a certain way uh my previous work with
kulia verb job on which proves single
exponential bonds on the number of
homotopic types of fibers definable maps
so might be you can think of this as the
case of the theorem with the
sheet upstairs such as the constant
shift
and then
singly exponential size covering by
contractibles and that relates to your
question
so we have developed from some other
purposes an algorithm which is single
exponential complexity that gives you
covering of a given semi-algebraic set
by
semi locally closed similarity like sets
which are
contractible and so if you are given a
subordinate partition with elements you
know just locally constant but if you
now cover it by contractibles then they
will become constant but you pay a price
it goes thing like but single
exponential is so big that these kind of
things don't matter
so there's some delicate
thickening and shrinking arguments here
when you're dealing with locally closed
stuff
some spectral sequence
and some basic theorems of constructable
shapes which goes into this proof which
is kind of warm
do you appeal to the latest theorem
about the um let's say you mentioned
some single exponential yes yes
it really uses all kind of machinery
that has been developed for dealing with
semi algebraic sets
okay so now the complexity aspect of
this and might be
get to maurice's question at the very
end
so let's recall
so
the definition of bloom should smell
complexity classes and i must apologize
to one of the authors of this because
i'm i'm going to mangle this definition
but
he'll see
okay
so
we have been so of course here in the
bloomberg cells a language is a
sequence of subsets of rmn
so i will introduce some notation i'll
call s
to denote the category of sequences
where m n is some non-negative function
and now we say that as such a sequence
is in
pr in the bss sense if there exists a
bss machine which recognizes this
sequence in polynomial many steps
now recall these these maps are
introduced right in the beginning
go from m to m over two in these
directions so you have sequences of
those maps for each m
now the class this polynomial class has
a nice property which is reminiscent of
the property of semi algebraic set it's
a stable
undertaking uh products
set theoretic operations but all of
sequences here
uh and even pull backs
so
pr is closed under security corporation
products and pullbacks why are you under
pullbacks well it's just
10 seconds of thought that if you have
sequence which is in polynomial time
pullback should be also in polynomial
but what about the stability under these
two other functions that brings us
so these functors here and that's the
reason i
defined this category of sequences
induced in a natural way
and now this becomes endo functors
because it goes from s to s
i'm only writing them in different
directions to stress their jointness but
so this one okay so they are still
they have this adjoint property
and we have the following obvious
equality and inclusions
namely that if you apply to the
so remember that
the pr is a
sub
set of sequences in s
so you apply pi star
you get you get back vr
it's closed under
this pullbacks
but if you apply these two
then you certainly get something that's
in pr
but we do not know
whether these inclusions are strict or
not
in fact
for
historical reasons
it's traditional to denote this
image here as npr and the other one as
co-npr
and
it's might be this is a better class
which is a polynomial hierarchy the
union of all these guys which well in
fact this np definition of np and coin
is not quite satisfactory because
uh these classes are not closed under
said theoretic operations right because
you don't know
a priori whether the complement of a
thing in nba is in here but not so much
it's better to take the union and that
relates to james question so
this one is if you take the union of
those two then they are closed under
standard operations
and
then you can iterate these uh
these pointers
by taking so pi epsilon all might be
composition
uh maybe i wrote it in the wrong way so
it goes from m to m over two and then
from your two to n r four
so now all this is very suggestive uh so
what happens if we try to replace s by
uh cs
so we should
we should
want to have a definition of a good
definition of the constructable shifts
which are simple now when you define
constructable sheets there are two parts
to it so the partition
which is subordinate and the stocks
which needed to be bounded in the
complexity result we are talking about
bounding the complexity of the partition
as well as bounding the complexity of
the stocks when you apply
so you might not so this is what so this
is uh
but i'll give a formal definition in the
next slide but this is my opinion of
what a simple class should be might be
i'm not saying that this is the best
definition but
as james said in his talk it's my talk
so i can make my own definition
so informally and here we should be
careful
that
we say a class sequence of constructable
shifts on rm
is simple within pr
if there exists a sequence of partitions
of rn
subordinate for each end which is
supporting the dfn
but this partition is allowed to have
exponentially many pieces but you should
be able to do point location efficiently
so given a point you should be able to
locate which element
and you should be able to compute the
pancreatic polynomial of the stocks
for every x efficiently
meaning in polynomial number of steps by
bss machine given x in rn you should be
able to do these in polynomial many
steps
no yes
what what is t i
uh t i uh t raised to i so i'm just
packaging all the very numbers into a
polynomial so that's usually called the
poincare polynomial
yes that's the generating function
that's right sorry indeterminate which
is not of any real consequence here
these these conditions don't care about
the difference do these conditions care
about the difference between
that sheath and the constant
venture sheath
well the partition will be different
right
um okay so more and by the way i must
say that this definition is not
completely so in work of peter and
felipe and also my work on previous like
taurus theorem that maurice referred to
this kind of
uh thing is was there so no one took the
plunge to actually define complexity
classes of sheep so that's what i'm
trying to do
so more formally
we say a class of sheep's
sequence is a
um
in this simple class if there exists a
index set which you might as well assume
to be
all integers
from one to two raised to
polynomial
and
and such that the dimensions of the
stocks are bounded singly exponentially
and vanish outside some polynomial
dimension
and such
and these now comes the two important
thing that these two sequences are
functions that goes from taking a point
in rm
to
the index set and the polynomial and
computing the poincare polynomial should
be computable by bss machines in
polynomial many steps
notice that the number of bits needed to
represent the elements i n there may be
exponentially many pieces
as well as the coefficients of the
pancreatic polynomial are bounded
polynomially and by this definition
could possibly compute this
okay so there are many examples and i
have no time to go over them but they
generally do generalize the usual
polynomial class if you take the index
um okay so that's another example let's
skip this
rank stratification shift is another
example let's skip that
but now
we have uh things which are reminiscent
of the bss complexity class
that this class is stable it needs a
little bit of proof but under all sorts
of easy
shift theoretic operation is also stable
under pull backs
but then what about
the direct image functor
and here we make a definition and this
definition just follows from the what i
proposed before
so we look at sequences of constructable
shifts
we again have a similar junction
and
we have these inclusions
and this
equality so we now define which
the class lambda r
as the closure of the direct image shift
under these easy operations
so again we have some examples which
skip but let me just end
with the main conjecture
which is that these are not equal to so
there's some relation with the classical
complexity bss complexity that it's
so this one is more or less uh
easy consequence of definition i snuck
in a c in there
which refers to not the original bss
class but this compact fragment of it
that has been defined by me and theory
zell
but in fact a stronger statement is
probably true but i put it in purple
because i'm not
sure that in fact
separation from p and ph already implies
that these are not equal so in any case
you can formulate these questions let me
end
with
do uh but
the
some
future directions that i think could be
interesting to
study
it was very very quick yes i'm sorry
it's the answer
yes so it is the analog of both np and
coinp
it was somewhere on the yes so
very bottom of some slide
very popular
so we have a class of simple sheaves
it's closed under taking pull back so
these are the
pullbacks and push forwards that are
joined not so difficult to show that the
same kind of
inclusion is true
now we want to define lambda
as the image
of vr under the push forward except that
we would also like to close it
under
operations like this
which are the easy operations
under which pr is itself closed
and for so might be even in the ordinary
set theory case one should do it because
np is not closed under taking set theory
i mean a priori
and uh
i want to make this
false and then you can iterate
so you project
close iterate object
any other questions
so
uh constructible sheaves also have like
once you know the stock you're supposed
to also know the generalization maps
that go to nearby
this theory does not
if i put that in would that change the
complexity i do not know that i mean
that would be an interesting thing
yes just one question why did you say at
the very beginning that separating let's
say this lambda from
this curved p
could be easier than doing the similar
separation
yes because of this
because of these implications
if you can do that then it will imply
this but
this is compact
this is compact that's right so in fact
one of my
open questions
yes to understand the notion of this
properness restrictions and the proper
so properness restrictions
uh you know in this comes in mainly
because i'm using the proper base change
theorems and this requires some
properness of maps restricted to the
support of the shift and which easy way
of getting it is just uh
and then there is a well so there are
other
so since i've been talking in terms of
inverse
arrows which are a joint there are other
pairs of like the tensor home
adjunctions
uh
any other such pairs in sheep theory and
you can ask you know kind of categorical
sense that you have a sequence of easy
things which is preserved under one
arrow
and you have an adjoint
maybe you can stratify so that it needs
uh stratum the
the map is proper
there is also also platinum
stratification channel you can stratify
and get them i don't know what which is
the notion of proper that you use the
usual notion of properness that the
inverse image of compact would have to
be compacted
yeah so
this is certainly impossible from o2 to
r yeah
no stratum anywhere
yeah this is for compact
i mean the image of any point is not
compact so you can compute the other way
but
the the problem with compactness has
come up before so
for instance these compact the reason we
introduced this compact fragment was
uh
some topological theorems
relating to
like the design spectral sequence
needs some kind of
properness
so if you ask the constructable function
question it seems to me um
almost obvious that you get the
equivalent complexity class with
functions and do it and how to say yes
so my original talk had the
constructable functions in the title
it might be i should say a little bit
so you have the class of constructable
sheets on rn
and as i mentioned
you can take the euler phone character
characteristic and you get a
contrastible functions
now constructable functions are very
ubiquitous like
in this
semester we have been talking about
ranks of tensors and things like that
which are all constructable functions
so you might want to develop a
complexity theory of constructable
functions at this level which is simpler
that's my last
and it's quite nice because if you have
this direct image here let's say pi
to csr to know r
two
we have the euler here
two constructable functions and r n over
two
so one problem with functions is that
functions can be tautologically pull
back but in the complexity questions you
are interested in p versus np are
pushing forward functions what does it
mean to take a function here and project
it or push forward this function so
normally in mathematics you push forward
functions by integrating along fibers
and here the in order to make this
suggestive diagram commute
there is only one way in which you can
push forward functions and that's the
so-called uh which is available for
your minimal and semi algebraic category
namely integrating with respect to the
euler palm carry characteristic
so then you can develop a theory of
constructable functions you
define what it means to be a sequence of
constructable functions to be simple and
then you get something that is allegedly
more complicated by pushing forward
under taking this kind of euler integral
and you can so i to me that corresponds
to something like the
vp versus vnp question in the bnp in the
bss model but unfortunately i didn't
have time and this theory uh it's
developed a little bit further
it is a theory of reduction and some
complete problems
okay so i i
talked further this rest of the week we
should thanks check out again